الكراهيه المقدسه وصف اطلقه برلماني روسي
الثلاثاء مشيرا لضربات بلاده ضد اوكرانيا
اعتبر عضو الدومى بوريست تاتني شوف تلك
الضربات فاريه وفق تقرير مجله يزويك وتوعد
الاوكرانيين بالتجمد والتعفن دون غاز او
اضواء او اي شيء هل ترجم قصف الاربعاء
سريعا الوعيد الروسي قال الجيش الاوكراني
ان دفاعته الجويه اسقطت الاربعاء واحد
وخمسين صاروخا روسيا من اصل 70 استهدفت
البنا التحتيه الحيويه لاوكانيا
ادى الاستهداف الصاروخي الروسي لمنشئه
بنيه تحتيه الى انقطاع المياه والكهرباء
في العاصمه سقط في القصف قتلى وجرحى لكن
يبقى ان تزامن استهداف البنا التحتيه
الاوكرانيه مع دخول الشتاء ينظر بمصير لا
يقل خطوره على الاحياء اصداء التصعيد
تجاوزت حدود راجعه حيث اعلن نائب رئيس
الوزراء في مولدوفا ان انقطاع الكهرباء
بضع ساعات عن نصف مدن البلاد نتج عن القصف
الروسي على محطات طاقه اوكرانيه ليست
الهجمات الاولى فلم يفرغ بعد خبراء وكاله
الطاقه الذريه من تفحص ما لحق بمحطه زبرج
النوويه مسجلين اضرار كبيره قالوا انها لم
تمس الانظمه الاساسيه للمحطه التي ما زالت
مفاعلاتها وفق قولهم مستقره حاليا لكن من
يامن وعواقب التجدد استهدافه منشات حساسه
كهذه مخاوف حملت الرئيس الاوكراني
فلودونيسكي على مطالبه الحلفاء الاوروبيين
باعلان روسيا دوله ارهابيه وكانت تجاوب
الاوروبيه على مستوى البرلماني معتبرا
الدوله الروسيه راعيه للارهاب ومستندا الى
ان الهجمات الروسيه في اوكرانيا تبلغ
مرتبه الاعمال الارهابيه ضد المدنيين
يواجه
الميداني الروسي الحالي في اوكرانيا هجوما
حادا من خصوم موسكو الذين يرون ما تقدم
عليه اله الحرب الروسيه فضائعه وليست فوات
او استثناءات للقاعده كما صرح وزير الدفاع
الامريكي قبل ايام تحث الحكومه الاخرانيه
مواطنيها على ترشيد استخدام الطاقه وتواجه
منظومه الصحه في اوكرانيا احلى كايامها في
الحرب على وقع اكثر من 700 هجمه وفق تحذير
منظمه الصحه العالميه